[Music]
on this Thursday night China's expanding
coronavirus crisis as cases multiply so
we're the number of cities under
lockdown tonight the race to create a
vaccine we're trying to move as quickly
as possible
Australia's relentless fire fight turns
tragic the crash of a Canadian water
bomber plus grounded the US may unleash
a crackdown on emotional support animals
our airplanes started to look like
Noah's Ark the potential impact on
Canada and crimefighter Olympic champion
and now I think it's gonna be one of the
highlights in my career
Canada's Megan Augusta scores another
big break
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
China the epicenter of a potentially
deadly virus has extended the lockdown
on more of its cities restricting travel
for millions of people as it ramps up
efforts to contain the spread of the new
coronavirus at the same time the World
Health Organization says it is still too
early to declare a global public health
emergency make no mistake this is though
an emergency in China but it has not yet
become a global health emergency it may
yet become one at least 18 people have
died and there are now more than 600
confirmed cases worldwide almost all of
them are in China only ten cases have
been confirmed outside China in Japan
South Korea Singapore Thailand the USA
and Vietnam there are no confirmed cases
in Canada and the Health Minister says
the risk here is low there are some
suspected cases though québec's health
minister says five patients are under
observation in quarantine at three
different hospitals in Montreal and one
in Quebec City a sixth person has been
cleared after it was determined they had
the flu we're of course looking at any
extra measures that need to be taking to
keep Canadians safe and to prevent the
spread of this virus we have complete
coverage tonight including what the
symptoms are and what's being done to
develop a vaccine but we begin with the
situation in China where those lockdowns
are in place in several cities and
hospitals are struggling to manage all
the people who are showing up to be
tested for the virus Redman Shannon has
our top story a mega city of 11 million
people on lockdown at the busiest travel
time of the year almost everyone outside
is now wearing masks including security
forces medical staff and the busy
hospitals appear to be taking every
precaution as you guys can see the
streets are a bit empty Canadian medical
student D Kamara lives in Wuhan and has
been filming as the city prepares
as you can see the situation here
is critical all public transportations
here have been suspended until further
notice it's a bit concerning but there's
no real actual panic as things here are
being handled in a calm manner as of
10:00 a.m. local time on Thursday no one
was allowed in or out of the city later
in the day the city of Wang Gong 60
kilometers away was also closed off
followed by traveler strick shenzhen
nearby a Jew and the smaller cities of
Kirby and chi gong that's devastating
for citizens during this holiday season
in China even in the capital Beijing
1000 kilometers from the outbreak Lunar
New Year celebrations have been canceled
after authorities confirm the first
death outside of the region where the
virus originated in a much awaited
announcement the World Health
Organization says this is a health
emergency in China but not a global
emergency yet we know that most of those
who have died had underlying health
conditions such as hypertension dabit or
cardiovascular disease that weakened
their immune systems the w-h-o says
cases so far of human-to-human
transmission appear to be isolated to
within family groups there is still a
lot we don't know we don't know the
source of this virus we don't understand
how easily it spreads and we don't fully
understand its click clinical features
or severity Redmon joins me now Redman
China was criticized for how it reacted
to the SARS outbreak and there are
concerns that may have been slow to
react in the case of this new virus what
are experts saying about that well Donna
the w-h-o is praising China for
identifying the genetic sequence of the
virus and for sharing it with them and a
virologist in a US lab that helped
identify SARS told me that China is
applying the lessons learned from SARS
and appears to be doing everything that
it can right now given that this is a
very new virus he also told told me that
he expects more in
important information to come out of
China within the next week or two Donna
all right Redmon Shannon in London
thanks the w-h-o says there are a lot of
unknowns about this disease from the
source to how it spreads and its
clinical features it's important to note
not everyone who gets it dies from it
they do know about one quarter of people
with confirmed cases have become
seriously ill here's what China's Health
Commission has released about 17 of the
people who have died 13 were men four
were women the youngest was a 48 year
old woman the oldest were 2 89 year old
men the w-h-o says those who have died
had underlying conditions such as
diabetes heart disease or Parkinson's
coronaviruses are named for the spikes
that protrude from their membranes which
resemble a Sun's corona and they can
infect both animals and people they
cause illnesses of the respiratory tract
ranging from the common cold to
pneumonia signs of infection include
fever cough shortness of breath and
breathing difficulties for now there is
no specific treatment for people who
have it work is underway on a vaccine in
a number of labs around the world
including here in Canada
Heather Eurex West reports in this
University of Saskatchewan lab
researchers are trying to do something
that's never been done before
part of our Institute's mission is to
respond to emerging virus threats and
this new virus this new corona virus in
China would certainly represent one of
those the vito inter vac lab recently
got the green light from the public
health agency of Canada to start working
with the new corona virus it's now in
phase one building samples of the virus
using the genetic sequence released by
Chinese health officials my lab
primarily works on MERS coronavirus so
we have experience in this area outside
Canada other labs are already working on
this a global coalition set up in 2017
to fight epidemic diseases just
announced funding for three separate
research teams who are also trying to
develop a vaccine one of them in oviya
Pharmaceuticals has shown some promising
signs it hopes to have a vaccine for
this corona virus ready for human trials
by summer most recently we worked with
our partners to get a vaccine against
the Zika virus from bench to clinic and
we did that in about
seven months so we're working very hard
to do this even faster it's an evolving
situation and where we're trying to move
as quickly as possible but until a
vaccine is developed there is little
that can be done to prevent this threat
making containment all the more
important Heather your ex West Global
News Calgary and here's a note about how
indestructible some viruses can be a
research team from China and the u.s.
traveled to Tibet in 2015 and they
discovered 33 virus groups including 28
viruses unknown to modern science they
were locked away in the Earth's oldest
glacial ice an ice cap that is 15
thousand years old now to some breaking
political news out of Ottawa another
conservative who was widely expected to
run for the party's leadership said
today he's out
Pierre Pauli of an MP from Ottawa will
not enter the race or Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson joins me
Mercedes why is he passing on a chance
at the top job well Donna pierre-paul
eov says that family reasons are at the
heart of his decision not to run that
the demands of becoming leader were
simply too much time away from home the
packed schedule and of course all of
that travel Paul EF tweeted about it
saying my heart is not fully engaged in
this leadership race without being
all-in I cannot be in at all so I've
decided not to seek the leadership at
the party at this time now as you can
imagine that news came as a tremendous
shock Pierre Paul EF had a powerful
leadership team behind him a lot of
organization and a lot of money and
Donna he was scheduled to announce his
campaign on Sunday so he's really
backing out here at the last minute and
that came is a great disappointment to
many on his campaign staff senior staff
were desperately trying to convince him
not to quit right up until the last
minute but said that they could tell
that his mind and his heart really
weren't in it this now means the
campaign is down to Erin O'Toole and
Peter MacKay one big question is where
the social conservatives will go now
because they were backing Paul yath and
there's also frustration among many
high-profile candidates that so many
have been dropping out of the race
including former interim leader Ronnie
Ambrose who dropped out just yesterday
ok Mercedes in Ottawa thanks the
International Court of Justice has
delivered a victory for Roy hinge of
people calling on Myanmar to
enact emergency measures to protect them
there are injured people remain at
serious risk of genocide under the terms
of the Genocide Convention in a
unanimous decision the court rejected
Myanmar's argument the rear engine died
in an armed military conflict it's the
first step in a legal case that could go
on for years
the judges ordered Myanmar to comply
with the order and file regular reports
the ruling is final and without appeal
but the International Court of Justice
has no real way of enforcing it more
than seven hundred and thirty thousand
Rominger fled Myanmar after a military
crackdown in 2017 UN investigators
conclude the campaign was executed with
genocide 'el intent britain's prime
minister says the UK has passed the
brexit finish line parliament has passed
the legislation implementing the
withdrawal deal and the Queen has given
it royal assent I paved the way for one
final formality and now needs approval
from the European Union's Parliament
before January 31st it's been nearly
four long years since voters narrowly
opted for brexit in a referendum there
are heavy hearts in Australia tonight
three American firefighters helping
fight the wildfires there have died in a
plane crash there was a large fireball
associated with the impact of the plane
as it hit the ground they were in a
Canadian tanker carrying fire retardant
that crashed during a fire bombing
mission in the state of New South Wales
the c-130 Hercules plane was sent to
Australia in August to help with the
crisis the plane was leased by a US
subsidiary of a company based in BC and
is now grounded its entire fleet pending
a full investigation in Quebec police
continue to search for five snowmobilers
from France who fell through the ice on
a river police and military helicopters
spent most of the day searching for them
and divers scoured the water five men
disappeared on Tuesday after their
snowmobiles plunged through the ice in
the provinces Lac saint-jean region
there from eastern France and they range
in age from 24 to 58 a mayor in France
who knew two of the men says they were
experienced snowmobilers who'd been to
Canada before their guide who was from
Montreal died in the hospital
today the Quebec government said guides
and tourists who use off-road vehicles
will be required to take a training
course for the seventh day a state of
emergency is in effect in st. John's and
now there are new concerns more snow up
to 25 centimetres is forecast for Monday
the Premier of Newfoundland and Labrador
says the cleanup costs from the monster
storm last week will be in the millions
and he's asking the federal government
for help we're watching very closely
what money looks like and what an extra
20 or 25 centimeters the snow could mean
to this area we've reached out and and
sent correspondence to the federal
government requesting consideration for
financial assistance in the meantime
people in the community are getting on
with it and making the best of things a
group dubbed the snow angels is going
around Saint Johns shoveling streets and
roads and digging out cars 400 troops
remain on the ground they'll stay as
long as they're needed we caught up with
some of them today clearing out the
front walk of a city snow plow operator
he's been too busy clearing the roads to
get to his own house it's been 75 years
since a schvitz was liberated
coming up the stark warning from world
leaders about the rise of anti-semitism
world leaders have gathered in Israel
and made an extraordinary call to be
vigilant for signs of anti-semitism it's
been 75 years since outfits the Nazi
death camp in occupied Poland was
liberated more than 1.1 million people
most of them Jewish died in that one
camp just a fraction of the six million
Jews who were killed in the Holocaust at
Yad Vashem the memorial in Israel to the
Holocaust Holocaust survivors along with
40 dignitaries and leaders came together
including the presidents of Russia
France and Germany plus Britain's Prince
of Wales the world Holocaust forum is
the largest diplomatic event in Israel's
history leaders were told their
countries should not take for granted
the common values people fought for in
world war ii israel's prime minister
said for the jewish people
ouch Fitz is more than an ultimate
symbol of evil it is also the ultimate
symbol of Jewish powerlessness it is the
culmination of what can happen when our
people have no voice no land no shield
the ceremony was held not just to
remember the past but to make a pledge
about the future and remind the world no
society no democracy is immune to
anti-semitism the industry of mass
murder of six million Jews the worst
crime in the history of humanity it was
committed by my countrymen and I wish I
could say that we Germans have learned
from history once and for all but I
cannot say that when hatred is spreading
the lessons of the Holocaust are
searingly relevant to this day 75 years
after the liberation of Auschwitz
Birkenau hatred and intolerance still
lurk in the human heart still tell new
lies adopt new disguises
and still seek new victims 75 years on
the lessons of the Holocaust are still
searingly relevant today
[Music]
we'll be back in a moment
[Music]
in Italy scientists have discovered new
evidence of the gruesome way some people
died when Mount Vesuvius erupted back in
the year 79 they have determined this
shiny black material is actually a human
brain researchers now think people may
not have been vaporized by the
superheated gas on volcanic matter but
faked and suffocated
it's the first time vitrified brain
matter has been discovered the u.s. is
putting a leash on the long list of pets
that are cleared to fly on some airlines
as emotional support animals many people
do carry-on dogs and other pets like
cats to deal with anxiety or PTSD but
others are accused of abusing the system
now that could be coming to an end as
Mike look at or reports until now
they've been able to fly for free the US
Department of Transportation is
proposing new restrictions on what type
of animal air travelers can claim is a
service or emotional support aid thereby
allowing the animal to travel inside the
passenger cabin on the house airlines
say it was getting a little out of
control with passengers going beyond
dogs and cats claiming their peacock pig
and even a miniature horse was a service
animal or emotional support our airplane
started to look like Noah's Ark we had
every kind of animal there could be and
we had every kind of safety and health
issue because of it but some air
passengers rights advocates say that's
an exaggeration the u.s. is suggesting
only dogs trained to help someone with a
disability will be considered a service
animal and they'll be allowed inside the
cabin the pendulum went too far
there was a legitimate concern that a
few people may be abusing the system
what I would have liked to see long ago
is significant penalties for those who
abused the system
o Canada doesn't have regulations for
service dogs yet those are coming into
effect in June phase 1 will only cover
service dogs that have been given
special training
so until then passengers have to follow
the rules imposed by their airline
WestJet has an extensive list of support
animals it bans for health and safety
reasons including hedgehogs and sugar
gliders which if you're wondering is a
type of marsupial it's long as a they're
not like loud and like in the way of the
flight attendant to the staff I see
nothing wrong with it I mean if you need
the emotional support animal you should
have them there that's why you have the
animal the Canadian transportation
agency is asking Canadians to weigh in
as it consults the public on phase 2 of
the rules which will include untrained
emotional support animals other than
dogs mike lacouture global news Ottawa a
retired anchorman and co-founder of the
nightly newscast on public television in
the US has died for 36 years Jim Lehrer
helped deliver the news on PBS he
co-hosted with his longtime partner
Canadian journalist Robert MacNeil PBS
says he reported the news with a clearer
sense of purpose and integrity even as
the world of media changed around him
Lehrer also became known as the dean of
moderators frequently taking part in
presidential debates
he retired in 2011 PBS says Larry died
peacefully in his sleep at the age of 85
duty and on the ice next a BC police
officer swaps her badge for blades at
the NHL all-star weekend
more than 200 skiers were stranded on a
broken chairlift in Quebec last night it
happened at around 7 o'clock at the
Berlin Ski Resort mechanical failures
stopped the chairlift and when it
couldn't be fixed staff used a harness
and cables to get people down one by one
some skiers say they were stuck for four
and a half hours there'll be some new
faces at the NHL all-star weekend new to
the NHL but certainly not to hockey ten
women will represent Canada including
Megan Augusta from BC she's already got
three Olympic gold medals and a silver
plus she's a police officer but this she
says will be a moment of a lifetime
Robin Gill explains why when Megan
Augusta is on a rink it calms her
the 32 year old is already mentally
prepared to go to the NHL all-star game
personally I think it's gonna be one of
the highlights in my career Augusta has
four Olympics under her blades the last
time Team Canada got together was at the
2018 Winter Games it was a heartbreaking
loss to the Americans in a shootout
Team USA won gold Canada was left with
second place silver now the two teams
shall meet again in a three-on-three
competition to be able to play against
you know one of the best countries in
the world you know it's always a battle
and it's we're gonna go there and we're
gonna have a lot of fun but it is gonna
be a battle for you know the 20 minutes
that we have constable Megan Agosta six
years ago
Augusta became a constable with the
Vancouver Police Department between
fighting crime and raising a daughter
she's had to find time on the ice she's
the only member of the women's team to
hold a full-time job while the others
get to breathe hockey on a regular basis
one of the my biggest challenges is
living here in Vancouver there's no
women's league so I find myself
practicing with the [ __ ] triple-a guys
in some ways she's going it alone on the
west coast but when she and her team get
together for the all-star game it will
be an opportunity to make a statement
about women in hockey we need to have a
professional women's league and we need
to get women's hockey to you know where
it deserves to be and that's playing the
game we love eating sleeping training
like the men
and getting paid and being financially
stable while doing it politics aside
Augusta is ready to play hockey is her
passion and she still has her sights set
on the Olympics in 2020 - because she's
far from being done with the game Robin
Gill Global News Surrey BC and that is
global national for this Thursday I'm
Jonah Friesen tonight's your Canada is
108 Mile ranch in BC thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]